paul daycare charles moore with ab2
appointments you'd welcome like steve
baker
well i think the um whole idea of
announcing appointments before a process
has actually taken place is a bit
strange and
i think the public will be wondering
where the government's priorities are on
this why are they worrying and
interfering in in an open process an
appointment for bbc and head of offcom
both
two very senior independent public
service posts that carry significant
salaries
why the government interfering in that
sort of thing when they should be
concentrating on getting a grip on test
and trace
keeping corona virus rates under control
and getting the economy back on track
um you talked about process there but
how about the actual
men themselves do you think paul daycare
would be a good choice to be the chair
of ofcom
i'm not going to comment on individuals
being trailed as potential heads of the
bbc or heads of ofcom you know when when
an appointment is made
and announced and we'll take a position
and we'll take a view and comment on it
then
um but but the fact is that you know the
the bbc
and ofcom are um integral to our
national interest
ofcom regulates the bbc they should be
free from political interference they
should be impartial
and and the stuff that's being trailed
about these appointments is quite
worrying
okay um i understand you don't want to
get drawn on commenting
too much on the appointments and paul
baker once said that bbc journalism is
reflected through a left-wing prison
that affects everything
it exercises a kind of cultural marxism
do you think he's right
i don't think he's right i think if you
look at the bbc and you will have people
complaining that it's too left-wing and
it's presentation of political issues
you'll have people complaining that it's
too right-wing and the fact that they're
both complaining suggests to me that
it's probably got
got it somewhere right in the middle of
it and um
and so the bbc is very important to us
you know the bbc is what spring that
brings us together in times of national
crisis we've seen that during covid
um it helps educate children at home
during bite size
it's incredibly important for our soft
power abroad in terms of the world
service and it's something we should
treasure now i'm not saying it's perfect
no organization is perfect but we you
know we
if it goes and if we don't have a bbc as
we know it as an independent
impartial broadcaster we i think we'll
really regret that
okay um i'm keen to talk to you a little
bit about the current
situation with kovic 19 as well so many
people living now
under local restrictions local lockdowns
and city khan wants to tighten up things
in london to stop people
visiting each other's houses is that
labour's position now
well there are local lockdowns all over
the country my constituency card of
central our city goes into lockdown at
six o'clock this evening because
rising rates you know we have a public
health crisis
coronavirus rates are increasing um
the test and trace system is broken and
what weekly on london
uh the question was specifically on
london i understand that there are
millions of people living under local
lockdowns too
um sydney khan says that he wants to
tighten the restrictions in london is
that labour's position
well if the if the evidence is that the
right rates are rising
to a point where you need to have local
lockdowns then yes you should have local
lockdowns and you take the scientific
evidence and the medical evidence on
that and make the decisions accordingly
but if we if you know the whole point of
these local lockdowns
they're happening because our test and
trace system is not
effective and it's no good for the
government to keep saying week after
week in prime minister's questions and
when ministers come to the dispatch box
and painting this picture that
everything is okay because it isn't
the government needs to get a grip on
test and trace and isolate
and if they can do that it's in all our
interests that that works
we can avoid increasing the number of
local lockdowns that have to happen and
obviously
if there's a local lockdown in london
that affects significant numbers of
people much more than any city across
the uk
without wanting to under play the
difficulties with test and trade which
have been very well documented
there is also a degree of personal
responsibility isn't there um research
out this week by kings called
london showed only 10 of people asked to
isolate
when contacted by nhs test and trace
actually did so
only 18 of people with covid19 symptoms
actually
self-isolate are you worried that well
frankly people are being a bit selfish
well i think that part of the reason why
we're not seeing high levels of
compliance comes back to
the lack of clear communication from the
government you know we want pretty clear
communication if nhs takes a test and
tries to ring you up and say you should
self-isolate and then you don't
in those cases if you are contacted and
asked to self-isolate you should
self-isolate you know people should
follow the guidance
but there you know there's a lot of
confusion out there and
we need three things to happen we need
test and trace to work effectively we
need to have sufficient testing capacity
we then need clear communication from
government about what people need to do
and when they need to do it so that
everybody can understand it because it
is very confusing
you know there are lots of people
telling me every week in my constituency
and i hear it from my colleagues
that people aren't clear about what they
are not and what they are allowed to do
and then we need to get the economy back
on track and we can't do that third
thing
unless those first two things happen
okay i'm talking about you know clear
direction as you have been um i'm
interested to get your thoughts on
uh sporting events in particular because
of course we've seen the uh delay
of live crowds uh going to spawning
events that's fine of course if you're a
premier league club you've got lots of
money through
uh tv rights but for struggling lower
league clubs and
lots of other sports as well this could
be you know putting you at risk of going
under
because you're so reliant on ticket
sales what specifically
needs to happen so we have been warning
the government
um since the start of the summer that
this was coming i mean this is not a
surprise we know that lower league clubs
in football
are completely reliant on ticket revenue
and this is no different from any other
sector of the economy where you need
to have targeted support to the sectors
that can't operate or can barely operate
because if you you know you've got
something like lower league football if
you've got something like
arts and culture and live entertainment
or the aviation industry or hospitality
if there's no income coming in then
there are you know there's not the money
to pay salaries so the government
rather than taking passion but but one
one size fits all approach is not
working and that's why the announcement
this week from the chancellor was so
disappointing because rather than target
those specific sectors that need the
help
and he's taken a one-size-fits-all
approach again and that's not going to
work that is going to help
trigger mass unemployment like we have
not seen since the 1980s
[Music]
for months we've been calling for
targeted support the premier league have
actually said
that they are ready to help we are ready
to help as a labour party to help the
government
come up with a plan we need to see a
plan from the government about what
they're going to do for sport
and this just doesn't affect football as
you say this affects rugby okay
all sorts of sports because we want to
see these survive in six months
time there needs to be some targeted
clear support and a plan
now okay now we've seen some pretty
difficult stories uh recently about
university students it's a really hard
time to be a young person you're often
away from home for the first time
you can't go to freshers week in the
same way that you would now you're told
many of them that they have to
self-isolate and that they may not even
be able to go back to their families for
christmas
and should university students be
allowed to return home at christmas even
if
it does risk spreading the virus
we have to put safety in public health
first obviously but we have said labour
has said we think that students should
be allowed home at christmas
and to enable them to do that we need an
effective
test trace and isolate system in place
universities have worked incredibly hard
to get universities ready across the
country for the arrival of students this
term and particularly for freshers
and i know you know as a parent of a
student fresher i know what parents and
students
are feeling at the moment incredible
levels of anxiety
and children coming home for christmas
then well i'm you know i
i'm worried about the fact that students
are you know it's supposed to be a great
time in your life you go off to
university
you're going to a new city to live
you're making new friends they're
missing out on all of that experience
and if we can get the test and trace and
isolate system up and running
effectively
that will allow students to be able to
come home at christmas to their families
which at the moment matt hancock refuses
to say can happen
now i know that there are particular
universities cardiff university for
example in my constituency
has inc is testing every single student
and their staff on arrival at campus
gavin williamson
should be talking to universities to
make sure that they can all do that and
put support in place for them to do that
and we need to see him come to the house
of commons tomorrow to tell us exactly
what he's doing
to help universities and help students
through this because we've had silence
now we were speaking to steve baker uh
earlier who said that he's putting
forward this amendment to allow
parliament to have a say before any new
restrictions come in
he said that if the opposition parties
support it he's confident there'll be
enough votes for that amendment to pass
so
yes or no would be absolutely fine we'll
labor support that amendment
we have our own amendment which we have
tabled it will depend which ones the
speaker selects for a debate and a vote
and we have some sympathy with the the
amendment that graham brady has tabled
but we want to see something which sets
out which our amendment sets out which
is about more transparency about
publishing the data between decisions
and a clear plan
just talking about a clear answer would
be really so if the steve baker
amendment the grain
brody amendment is selected will labour
back it
if it's selected i think that the
likelihood is that we would back it but
we would like to see our amendment
debate debated and voted on so let's see
which one the speaker goes for